When the earthquakes hit, we were out of bed
in quite a hurry.
Then we heard the sirens and of course following
the sirens was a voice.
And we just, Barbara actually wanted to leave,
she said, "I want to get out of here".
So we packed up the dogs, got in the car and
took off.
I didn't know there was a siren here in Woodend,
I did not know that and I live here
and talking to the neighbours, they didn't know either.
We bumped into a lot of people in Rangiora
where we were and talking to them, they were
just confused.
Absolutely.
Definitely.
We'd like to know when they are and we'd go
along.
And why did they sound so long after the earthquake?
That seems weird to me.